what is suspension of disbelief
it's a way for you as a storyteller
to really immerse someone make them
believe
that they are in that world in that
space
and
it's a it's a storytelling um
i guess way of explaining how
you can really immerse someone
in an environment and in a situation
where they forget everything else
and they can be truly present
in um
in the world that you've created in the
story that you've created so being able
to suspend your audience's disbelief
in creating um you know if you're
walking into a space that's supposed to
look like you're going into a space
shuttle for example can you suspend your
audience's disbelief that for a moment
they truly are
and for
a lot of the times when an audience or a
visitor goes into an experience like
this they are
willingly
um
they willingly want to suspend their
disbelief because they want to
experience something that really
transports them into this other world
so
uh as a creator and as a storyteller how
can you
best
um
have that
environment have that world truly
capture their imagination
and meet and exceed their expectations
of what being in a space shuttle
would really feel like right and how can
you do that with
not only the um environment that you
create but maybe through movement
through murmur through sound through
scent
uh through what they
feel and touch and
hear and you know um
experience i think that that's something
as an immersive storyteller you need to
think about is how do you
suspend your audience's disbelief so
that they feel like
this is truly where they're walking into
and this is truly the world that in
their wildest imaginations has
come alive and come true for them
what tools can you use to get someone to
suspend their disbelief
i think you can use whatever tool is at
your disposal
i mean
i remember as a kid
going through the haunted mansion for
the first time in disneyland and wanting
to recreate my own haunted mansion in my
own
my cousin's actually bedroom
and
you work with
whatever you can get i mean whatever is
around you
you don't have to have a multi-million
dollar budget
you can work with
whatever it is you have at your disposal
at the time you know it was just moving
around furniture
using makeup to make ourselves look like
ghosts darkening the rooms having the
right music
and
a lot of
what you do to suspend an audience's
disbelief is
you're
allowing yourself giving yourself that
permission to really
open up your imagination and create
something unlike
anything you've seen before and i think
the ones that are truly
uh game changing in terms of using
tools in unexpected ways
or using
you know a different kind of medium to
be able to
suspend your audience's disbelief doing
it in a surprising way those are the
ones that really
speak to me those are the ones that
really uh surprise and delight me
because
it's not like you see you're inspired by
something and then replicate it in the
exact same way because there's plenty of
that going on around in the world right
how can you create something
that has your mark your personality your
perspective your tone
in a way
that
reshapes retells
that world that story in a way that's
unique and the way that is authentically
you
so
whether you all you have is a basement
or a storage unit
or uh you know if you do have a whole
mansion to play with you know i think it
really
it's up to you as the artist as the
creator as a storyteller
to really
think outside the box to think about how
to
use any tool at your disposal at your
disposal to really create something
truly unique
well you talk about in your book that um
when you read or watch a movie or even
hike that you're present finally because
especially today we're so distracted and
you talked about the urge to check your
phone even when you go in an elevator we
all do that but that you're truly
present when you're in a story
that that or even just in an environment
whether it's hiking or wherever so maybe
that's the real test is how present is
the audience and how can
we make them be present
so that they don't have an urge to to
pick up the phone or something else oh
yeah definitely i think that
and the real
test is when you see
real emotions right when you see you
know
nothing gets me more than
seeing you know
kids kind of like their eyes widen
because and children are really one of
the best i
i feel like the the most satisfying
audience members for me because
when you could see it in their eyes that
they believe
what they're seeing
that is magic
you know being able to
you as a creator storyteller magician to
conjure up a world in which they believe
they're in it and that they're living it
is something that all immersive
storytellers
should really strive for
um
to really suspend that disbelief and
and have them be present and have them
forget about everything else especially
with kids who are
very screen
you know they would rather the screen
among other things you know these days
and my nine-year-old son being one of
them
um we want to
create that those
worlds and environments and places for
them to play again
and
you know there's nothing wrong with
playing video i grew up playing video
games i watched a ton of tv and films
but it's all about variety
and
having that um
chance to really
forget about um
just the the daily routine
and really being present in a place
where
it's not it's not just about what you do
every day and uh the things to check off
the list or anything like that it's
being able to let go
giving permission
uh to yours for to yourself to be free
to explore to discover to play to engage
to interact with people that you
wouldn't normally interact with
to give you the
courage really to be in a story and in a
world where you might not
initially feel comfortable
about but really letting yourself go
to
enjoy it and to
participate
i think that
there's so many things going on in the
world where you can just sit back and
watch a thing
or be
passive observers
and as immersive storytellers we really
want our we really want people to step
in
and participate and to engage and to
interact and to act it's all these
active verbs
that we always think about when we
create an immersive story world
and that's how even when we think about
a museum
or a land or a ride or an attraction or
a show
sometimes
all you know sometimes the way that you
can think about it is what are the
active verbs that you want people to do
is it to explore
to
dive into this pool of sprinkles to go
down a slide to climb this ladder to you
know uh sit at a table where the plates
come to life um to
speak with a stranger that's next to you
to open a door that uh opens to a portal
into another world right it's all of
these things that
you know you as a audience member
participant
uh can have that opportunity to do
that's unlike anything that you can do
in your
ordinary life
and as a storyteller it's a really
great
privilege
for you to have to create that
opportunity for other people to immerse
themselves
in a world that they don't normally find
themselves in